thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing careful
boys where we are currently off the
Record and today whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa is your current partner is wiped
from existence whoa we're talking
Spider-Mans in Infinity wires no and I
don't feel so good Mr Stark no and he
wants to stay but gone let me delete our
number right now just to be more real
there you go
I don't know how I'm gonna live your
current partner is white from existence
they call it the blip which X gets
another chance oh it's an X Anthony go
you go first
it all went first today
you all did it we all opened up and
shared it could also be one that got
away that's not necessarily one you ever
got the one that starts with a J and
this has nothing to do with your current
partner oh they they got turned into a
[__] dust yeah like that
the one that starts with a J for Anthony
shut up what the [__] Joe why do you
look like neighborhood watch yeah dude
why are you looking about the Spy versus
spy dude
looks like it's a flash meme
I might go with my first ever girlfriend
of all time who I dated for one month
Steve's fault that makes me type more I
gotta type is it because uh you felt you
feel like
in my mind my rational right now is I'm
not picking any of my more recent
ex-girlfriends and just going back to
something that I more recently knew why
it didn't work but when I was young I
had I I had no idea you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah I have no idea I didn't
and I didn't experience a lot of things
with them so I have no idea so if I were
to genuinely practically think about my
Curiosities yeah they're already
satisfied in all of my last like Forex
girlfriends which didn't work yeah so
I'll go back to like my very very first
ones but what the [__] are you still
laughing
what are we doing guys he's like we
can't go to Disney then
oh that's what you're still on stupid
yeah what are we doing guys
oh my gosh
you're fine you're fine
oh
come on don't let Steve ruin it dude
we're just on the side okay yeah
okay so where are we at with this video
honestly that's not that's not bad I
mean if if I was to think about who
actually I would pick from my ex pool
people I don't have any kind of makes
sense which is what you're going with
it's like yeah we had an innocent ass
time and like yeah that that was
basically something that's undamaged by
some trauma [__] can I not have an X
but more like uh the ones that got aways
yeah sure who's the one that got away
similar story with Anthony it was
elementary school well you didn't tell
me what grade so much chemical story
Kimiko Kimiko
the girl in your story you mean the
princess yeah [__] dab the first
queen of Japan
Queen
no so I had a really close friend
um and his sister was like I had the
hats for her and [__] and then like but
we we became a couple in elementary
school by never being close to each
other but passing through people to be
like I like her okay I'll tell her and
then [__] oh that's old school he
likes you oh right she says that she
wants to marry you one day oh for real
and then like I get the notes and then
we'll pass notes and [__] but then she
was so damn shy that every single time
like you know your friends push you and
then you're finally you're doing one of
these things you're pushing back like
this way and then they push you from the
back like that and then you get close
and she's like red face giggling and she
[__] runs and so every single time my
friend knew this and he wasn't like that
weird kind of little brother he was kind
of like that cool little brother that
would be like yeah
yeah right and then so like I would come
over and play and then his sister would
come down and he would do some [__] to
embarrass her and she'll be like talking
[__] to him and then you know how like
siblings fight to like show off or
whatever and she would run away so I
never had a chance to actually sit the
[__] down next to her and have a
conversation and she was so hot
is it what is it about kids and like our
need to like it's like I already have a
best friend but like I need to be to be
my brother now because like if he [__]
and marries my sister then like because
you think it'll be closer it's like the
weirdest yeah it's like now we're like
brothers Brothers you know like that's
you know Step Brothers right yeah that I
feel like we can all relate with oh yeah
yeah we're [__] Brothers yeah that is
very relatable for us so it's such a
weird thing that we want to marry my
sister dude I had another best friend
his name was Aaron right this is the guy
that [__] wiped dog [__] all over my
back
[Laughter]
he was a little autistic but he thought
it was really fun like we things just
got out of control one day he picked up
dog [__] with his bare ass hands and he
thought it was so funny and he started
chasing me with it and I was running for
my goddamn life right and by the time he
got up to me he went bam and smacked my
back and smeared the living [__] out of
it like this and then I was like
his mom came home and his mom was hot
because she was like one of those young
ass moms and she was like what are you
doing always wore little shorts she had
the [__] Mexican Chola curly hair
with the [__] eyebrows and [__] she
looked like she could have been on low
rider magazines so hot everywhere we go
she always get like hit on and dude I
was she was like my like she was a
single mom
no she always had boyfriends oh my God
but um
but anyway she was like she was like oh
what are you gonna do so she got my
clothes [__] washed it she I got I
got a new pair oh before that we got to
play in the pool to clean up and [__] so
I got I was wearing his clothes and then
he was like oh I don't know what
happened I was just having too much fun
you know he was trying to say like
things got out of hand he couldn't like
say it but he had his sister right and
he wanted this brother thing with me but
his sister looked like the big girl from
Nacho Libre you know the one that chases
[__] uh Stephen like Shrek's wife
really big right she was massive and
then I remember when we had a sleepover
all three of us were knocked the [__]
out right this girl like so [__] big
she lost I lost my circulation out of my
leg cause she was her art like her body
was on my leg because her wrist was on
your leg
I woke up and I was like oh you made my
legs numb and [__] right and then I was
like I was like so mad and then her mom
was [__] shut up already
so after that
she's like Joseph I have this dream
you you were married with my sister we
were brothers and then uh part of me
wanted to be like yeah but then the
other part was like oh what the [__]
because you were offended I didn't want
to be with her right and he goes but
wait but wait she was hot and she was
skinny oh how sad that's what the
brother said so his awareness is the
same as yours yeah he said he said but
wait she was skinny he's good at
pitching yeah and I was like she wasn't
a torta yeah
she was hot like my mom she was more
like Mommy yeah
but yeah that was that was that moment
of when I was like you know what
she's not gonna always be fat
what I love about this story is that you
are dressed as smart as me flying back
to the future too and I wish you just
had a radio in your hand to [__] and
pull the intent out dock doc duck
something inconspicuous
his sister's not fat anymore
I got the almanac back it's [__] with
miff's house he's in disguise
I do want to see where they are today
and if she ended up being hot you gotta
find out did you ever look them up we
had the genetics for it
um now they completely disappeared they
went to Palmdale oh so they're just like
dead probably that they're probably dead
people
I'm no longer living yeah his
grandparents are they they had a Mexican
restaurant and then they went to Mexico
they you know everyone's gone can't find
them at least it's not West Covina then
we know they're dead
top 10 my ass dude
I would I would find what's up with that
girl that uh that girl that I dated that
tried to kill herself tried to smash her
head on the ground and got sent to
England yeah I would find her to be like
what the [__] happened man just to catch
up yeah that'd be a crazy story it was
like it was in a blitz wow yeah like her
cousin died she ended up getting sent
away she hit me up she hit me up years
later was super cuckoo so I'm like I
would wanted to I think out of everybody
I've ever dated she was the one most
interesting person but she probably also
lied about a lot of [__] so I would just
want to get everything squared out and
go what was real man yeah like what
happened
what makes you think she lied about a
bunch of stuff
because some so much stuff was like
odd didn't match up yeah and it was like
that was one of my first relationships
so I'm like we were both kind of dumb
and like
I just I don't know exactly whatever
became of her and the only person that I
know that knows her is like her her
cousin a different dude is like dude
even I don't know where she's at wow
like nobody knows what happened to her
yeah how old was she when she got
shipped away to London [__] away
I mean sent sorry 18 19. oh yeah that's
a tough age bro but yeah is she out
there being a Londoner I think she came
back that's the thing we don't know like
someone said she's in [__] San
one of those San Bruno landline you know
what you would actually say or is it
really just like hey what the [__]
happened dude do you think she would
register that and just go like I have no
clue that's the thing like I have zero
idea like she the next time she
contacted me she like hated me for no
reason are you guys like Network like
kind of connected like through church or
something like you guys kind of have
like
this Outer Circle of my people's nose
the Outer Circle of her peoples and
that's like a small degree of separation
still
no it was so early in my life that like
I don't know who she knows now you know
like we don't know who each other is
over maybe 10 years 20 years this was in
this was in 2001. oh wow so it's like
communication was just totally different
but yeah if if I if my current situation
just turned into thin air I would make
it a thing to just find her and be like
are you alive you know it's crazy
but yeah her name's her her name I would
say her name but to this day again her
all of her initials are still my
passwords on everything whoa
that's name with crazy ass like it was
like a great password she had six names
don't send the [__] to smash well she
knows she knows my passwords and I I've
told her that because it's just easy to
remember she has six names yeah she has
like one of those like crazy like well
she sees this video she could hack into
all your [__] what was your password she
could yeah why should you know your
passwords but then there's a bunch of
[__] after it but then the first all the
initials on all your other girls stuffer
all the ones that have died yeah and
then it ends in R.I.P but don't worry
it's a 33 character password
Ultimate Security yeah there's um what a
pimp this guy is yeah it's it's that I
would want to I would want to go find
when you guys look at your exes
you know like the first phase your life
oh you're brand new wow and then you get
to know them you're like I don't know if
this is working that well and at the end
you're like yeah it's not working right
I don't know that's the stages yeah
I don't know if there's any time like I
look back at a situation go you know
what maybe if we try it again and I know
there's other people out there that do
think that yeah because it's kind of a
prompt when he's saying right that is
thank you but this is great
it's called feedback
in this circle I don't feel like
we think like that I'm a no regrets guy
rag rats but if my wife got poofed like
that you know you gotta lean back on
some old habits
really but is it is that what you call
them but you know what you're getting
yourself into right it's not a fresh
start that's why that's what scares me I
just I just go back into the Improv pool
I'd crush it for a couple months
drama class who like grabbed your dick
and then now you gotta do the right move
but the rule is
that what makes this so hard is you got
to go back to your ex it's not starting
fresh it's not doing something nice
sorry how is this harder to imagine
answering than would you [__] your mom
or dad this is worse than that
hell yeah because [__] your mom or
dad it's a binary Choice yeah and chosen
I don't think we think like that
I'm with Joe where I feel like we are
people that like to move yeah so it it's
almost uncharacteristic to go backwards
so like for me if I were to paint myself
in a realistic situation and it but
still like answer the prompt it would
almost be if one of my at exes
uh organically came back into my life
yeah then it would make sense where I'm
like okay I would re-entertain this yeah
but unfortunately that's not the problem
they got turned into sawdust yeah yeah
yeah and now you have to make a decision
yeah so instead of everybody spending an
extra couple of minutes defending how
they're people of honor and integrity
answer the [__] questions that turned
into perfume
I don't think I have a casual
oh mine's easy mine's for sure the
chicken college that I didn't swoop in
fast enough and gave me yeah gave me
clear signs but I was too much of a
[__] to do anything but I think that
changes the question now because it's
we're all answering where it's not an x
uh except for me the guy who went first
again they said they literally you want
to pick again oh The One That Got Away
too
then that changes it and it works you
did answer it well though with the girl
that you mentioned yeah yeah that's true
it's someone that you would like had an
unfinished thing look I think for all of
us except for Anthony our chicks are our
chicks right
put another note in before Anthony says
ready
everybody get down
to the desk this is like Joseph
Gordon-Levitt in the dark knight rising
he's like okay here it comes get down
kids
I don't think I have any situation where
I left off a sit like a relationship
where I'm like you know what this could
have been good
and I could come back to it all of them
to me are like exploded there's none
that I'm going back to that's why I I
don't under I don't know but if this guy
has more cordial relationships